Amsterdam can give you maybe a bit of a
skewed picture of what is going on we
are a very small country and we are
extremely densely populated um I would
say yes maybe at first glance it doesn't
it doesn't look as bad as it is maybe in
in London or in Paris but it's a a
matter of time I think we're sitting on
a tiing time
bomb so a but you said something funny
to me or at least seemed funny to me a
minute ago which is that you got into
this thing a couple years ago and you
didn't realize that you'd never be able
to get out which I have heard that
sentiment from from many people who have
even sat in that chair in the last two
or three days uh for the people that
don't know you could you very briefly
talk about how you got involved in this
whole thing and then we'll talk about
the issues of the day yeah this whole
mess how did I get myself in this
position well I'm uh I'm 27 I'm Dutch so
my name is Ava ther bluk the last name
is always a tough one for we're going to
spell it properly yeah thank you thank
you it's a it's a tough one even for the
Dutch I really I need to get married you
know for multiple reasons but that's
definitely one of them would make my
life easier uh yeah I do political
commentary uh mostly for an
international audience right now cuz uh
not exactly liked very much let's just
say uh that way in my home country
especially not by the Legacy Media and
the establishment um so uh yeah I'm a
lawyer I uh I got started almost in a uh
yeah it was almost a coincidence I uh I
was in university as a law student and
um I this was during the refugee crisis
in Europe so
20145 and uh I was quite critical of the
the you know the general policies in
Europe Miracle's idea of just opening
the borders uh without any any stop or
limitation to it basically and I said
well guys maybe this is not a great idea
and that got me in trouble with my
professors with my fellow students and
um I spoke to a journalist about it uh
one time at an event and he's like would
you want to tell your story about you
know the the the leftwing hedony at the
University and and you know how you feel
like academic freedom isn't really a
thing anymore and I was like no I'll do
that I'll do that yeah I will change my
life overnight yeah and that's exactly
what happened and then I I came to
realize very quickly that um most of the
doors that I thought were open to me as
a young law student had closed and that
there was really no way no way back back
in only one way that was uh yeah forward
so I continued to speak out and I did so
first on a national level I had a brief
story in Dutch politics which was a
straightup disaster and then I figured
no I'm I'm going to go independent and
uh and take it to a higher level and do
my commentary in English so that's
that's kind of how that happened so for
people that don't know that much about
Holland I just mentioned to you I've
been there many times I a family there I
really loved the culture and in some
ways at least Amsterdam to me seems like
a place where some coexistence has
worked better maybe than a little bit of
what I'm seeing here in London or Paris
for example I'm not totally sure you
agree with me and that's just that's
just fine if not that's what I can tell
you as a tourist but feel free to offer
the cser um but the reason I bring it up
is because I don't think most people
have a sense of what's going on in
Holland they think about Amsterdam and
they think about coffee shops right what
would you want people to know about sort
of the makeup of H and I guess maybe the
geography and where it sort of sits
within what's going on across Europe
right now sure well I mean you're not
wrong if you go to Amsterdam um it it
seems especially if you're in the city
center that think it's cuz everyone's
stoned or you were
no kidding no it's a it's a it's it's
quite a segregated City so you know the
it's ruled by the left and a lot of
champagne socialists U so the housing
prices are are extremely high and so
nobody really can afford to live in the
city center and uh that pushes you know
the US usually the immigrants out yeah
uh and so we have just like in in in
French cities and stuff we have suburbs
that are highly highly uh dominated by
by migrant groups especially from
non-western countries because well just
like everywhere in Europe you know most
of the immigrants that we get are from
the Middle East or from Africa North
Africa but also subsaharan Africa a lot
of um Muslim immigrants come to come to
Europe so you know it's obviously a
difference between our immigration
influx and that's sense and um and the
the immigrants that you guys have coming
in through the southern border um so
Amsterdam can give you maybe a bit of a
skewed picture of what is going on we
are a very small country and we are
extremely densely
populated um I would say yes maybe at
first glance it doesn't it doesn't look
as bad as it is maybe in in London or in
Paris but it's a a matter of time I
think we're sitting on a taking time
bomb and we have open borders uh
obviously within the European Union so
people can travel freely which uh people
really like because you don't have to
show your passport the Border going from
the Netherlands to to Belgium but that
also means that everybody who comes in
anywhere within the EU can travel freely
so it in a way you know we already don't
have National sovereignty anymore so I
remember the first time I was there I
think was in 1997 and I took a train
from Amsterdam to Rome and I think you
basically have to go through four or
five count Belgium Luxembourg
maybe something else all the way to
Italy I mean you're basically within 20
hours in four different countries and I
suppose at any point you could hop off
and yeah live whatever life you want to
live which is a bizarre notion and it
happens right so a lot of the the
migrants that come in through for
example through Italy they go to
lampedusa first I'm sure you've seen the
footage recently you know it's being
swarmed um but usually people don't stay
there uh same thing with Eastern Europe
they don't stay there because the social
benefits are better in Northwest Western
European countries so they all come to
to Germany to the Netherlands to Sweden
Norway you know cuz we're uh yeah the
the nice liberal places you know that
offer offer the the the softest Landing
so to say so what what is going on with
the politics of Paul and you know
obviously uh we covered it a little bit
but probably should have done much more
and I should have you on again to
discuss it what's going on with the
farmers there uh but also Co stuff like
it seems like it's like a big Mex mix of
things and also you guys are not far
into Political violet Theo van go was
murdered on the street in Amsterdam 25
years ago and they pinned a note on his
body you know that they were going to
come after iand Al next of course you
know put her on on the map in a sort of
unfortunate way but yeah what's like a
general state of the political yeah it's
it's as it's good that you bring that up
because I I feel like a lot of the the
you know the topics that we talk about
with immigration and with the climate
activism and all of that we're talking
about it now and how bad things are now
but you're right um this was in 2001 and
2002 we had two big political murders in
the Netherlands one was ta he was
stabbed and Brad Daylight by an islamist
um and the year after that we had pimp
foron uh a conservative politician who
would have otherwise if he hadn't been
murdered would have become the prime
minister of the Netherlands and he was a
very uh he was a very flamboyant but
strong intellectual conservative and he
got shot by climate Act activist and
this so we're talking 200 this one
that's so bizarre yeah 20012 2002 right
so this is it's not as if the problems
that we're dealing with now are are you
know recent it's been going on for 20
years and nothing has changed since and
things have just basically gone worse um
we uh we've been ruled for 30 years now
by uh one specific party the vbd always
in a coalition format because we have we
don't have a two- party system we have
tons of parties um but yeah by the same
neoliberal you know just the only thing
that they care about free market and
open borders free market go you know
goes hand inand often times and they've
uh they've ruled with the left and uh
the policies have just been well in
terms of immigration detrimental but
agriculture is now under heavy attack
yeah can you talk about what's going on
there for a little bit yeah sure yeah
I've uh yeah I've been very involved in
the fight for the Dutch Farmers kind of
accidentally as well that how that
happened um but our all connected that's
how it happened yes yeah yeah so the
Dutch Farmers um we have a lot of
agriculture in the Netherlands we're a
small country but more than 50% of the
land is owned by Farmers we're the
second largest exporter of agricultural
products in the world right after the US
which is uh quite you know a large
position to have as such a tiny country
uh and we're we're super good at it you
know you have family in the Netherlands
and you probably know that this is
something that's in our blood the you
know it's it's a century old I've seen
all the tulip fields yeah yeah exactly
it exactly and so we're really good at
that and now suddenly our government has
decided that we have a nitrogen crisis
and that more than 30% of all of the
Farms need to go because it's bad for
the climate and uh it doesn't make any
sense you know technically they don't
even say it's bad for the climate they
say it's bad for the the state of the
Dutch nature which is funny you know
because everybody's been to the
generally thought of as good for nature
right and and it's we also to to think
that the people who own that land you
know would want to see it polluted or or
see it go bad you know they obviously if
you need it to be fertile and good soil
otherwise it wouldn't be in business so
it's the whole notion is just I think
it's all predicated on a lie and that in
essence it's it's just a way for the
Dutch government to take land away from
citizens which they desperately need and
they've admitted to that for um new
houses because we have a ever growing
population as a result of mass migration
and they don't know where to leave those
people is there any political will I me
bringing it back to migration since
that's sort of been the theve here I
love it um I mean is there any political
will now to to reverse some of this
stuff well when it when it's about
migration people talk about it a lot but
I feel like you know everywhere in the
Western World in that sense we're at an
impass uh because we still have our
borders wide open and then people are
talking about well we need to start REM
migration you know we need to start
sending people back home but we're all
part of all of these Universal
Declarations of Human Rights and then
you have a whole apparatus of lawyers
you know that say well you can't do that
because you're part of this this treaty
and that treaty and it would be uh it
would be a violation of their of their
human rights to to go and think about
remigration so we're just stuck you know
nothing ever really happens and I I feel
like we well you first need to to close
the doors you know close the gates
because um we have we have a saying that
translates weirdly to English but a
Dutch saying that's uh that goes
something along the lines of well you
know you can mop the floor but if the
tap is still open it's not really going
to do that much and I feel like that's
what what's happening with immigration
you know you can start talking about
remigration but if everybody's still
coming in through the back door then
it's um doesn't really make any sense
are you uh this is sort of how I've
ended a lot of these interviews are are
you hopeful not only for your country
but the West as all do you do you sense
that maybe the events of the last couple
weeks have kind of broken some people
out of their Slumber that seems to be a
bit of a them here not a solution but at
least an initial Salvo maybe right yeah
well I hope so I hope so I feel like
it's hard to deny reality you know when
you see here a 100,000 people out on the
street who are very clearly not just
there you know to support maybe
Palestine just Palestine but that
there's this this sort of cultural and
even ethnic component to the stance that
they're taking and uh it it becomes so
so visible I hope that even the sleeping
masses are like oh okay wait a second
but yeah I mean in a way too little too
late right it's uh the enemy isn't at
the gate you know they're they're in
they're in the bedroom they're in yeah
so it's um am I hopeful well my answer
to that always yes because you have to
be otherwise you know we're just going
to sit back and do nothing I'm also
being realistic though the numbers don't
look good you know the numbers really
don't look good and unless there is some
sort of intense you know public Revolt I
guess and then obviously in peaceful
ways um against the political
establishment I don't think that
anything is going to change so people
really do need to you know start voting
for at Le for the right parties the ones
that they that they've you know smeared
as as far right for the longest time and
I I think now it's U it's a question of
whether or not you you want a future not
about am I afraid to be maybe called far
right or or a Nazi or a racist or
whatnot it's like no those those terms
shouldn't hold any you know value
anymore coming from the people on the
left who've allowed all of this to
happen so let's fight let's fight if
you're looking for more enlightening
conversations about international issues
check out our International playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell